fire off a question no you so you guys
got to say you know introduce yourselves
and we're back to answer the internet uh
we're back to it we're back yeah yeah I
guess we are back to it we've done this
so we're back to answer the internet I
know but it's not like a continuing shut
up it's like an up and do it it's not a
new thing everybody who comes Chris
O'Connor this is Tommy Pope and this is
Anderson yeah but when people are
returning yes they [__] say that man
I just laughed so hard I farted did you
really yeah okay let's talk about the
intro Who's hotter
you set this up
no
oh sure dude is this a big thing yeah I
thought this was set up Jasmine all the
way no ISO was three yeah
let's go yeah that's the story I used to
I like I know action figures okay so
there's in my childhood bathroom there
was a toy cabinet that stayed toys until
I was like in high school
and like writing papers and stuff used
to give me such anxiety that I'd go to
the bathroom and jerk off and I would
jerk off on Jasmine's face there's an
action figure at Jasmine and I would
just look at her and fantasize and then
come all over yeah
[Laughter]
so I'm gonna go with the Jazz
it was like like a regular size action
figure yeah so you're just covering the
things
Jasmine dude
yeah yeah it was all in her hair mom can
you get Jasmine real quick
there were times when my mom knocked on
the door and I was like
yeah Chris we're recording
I I don't make you say [__] you know
it's so funny that she was like yeah no
I know I'm sorry because this is where
when when chicks are like no like I love
sex too I'm just like a guy it's like no
did you ever [__] come on an action
figure yeah because you're such a horny
[__] anxious person no yeah the [__]
out of here you have no idea you have no
idea the mind of a teenager
yeah yeah well who are you what are you
so are you I'm gonna go the other one
think about the type of women you like
you're way more Jasmine than Ariel no
you know I like Peggy Bundy
um she was my sweet spot at that age all
right
I was more Peggy I went I was the belt
curve wow yeah I went I went three I
went well we're talking Curtis she's
wearing [__] she's like leopard
big [__] heaters hanging out yeah
I'm in seventh grade trying to loosen
loot never not for me if every time you
got a boner the same song would start
playing what song would you want Daniel
by Elton John
Jesus Christ we'll calm down my blood
flow
and it'd be emotionally draining it's a
very sad songs yeah yeah well my brother
did die I would go with papas
[Laughter]
his ants are crying
are there sacred days when you refuse to
masturbate if you know you're gonna [__]
that night good no continue oh yeah you
say that if you know you're gonna [__]
that night you're gonna beat up on
purpose so that you can last longer no
you don't beat off so you can have more
of a more of a show yeah that's an
interesting question so you get in more
rounds too well sometimes when I have
less of a show I just go I beat off
earlier
yeah but if you already knew you were
gonna it's one thing if you like it you
just met somewhere and then you [__]
that night and it was like spur of the
moment but if you had a plan and then
you jerked off and then you got weird
dick it's like what were you doing well
to be honest like I get insecure about
like my load length and I'll be like
they don't care though
no I changed the position yeah I go get
a napkin I'm like don't move don't move
when I pretend like I'm cleaning the
whole table get the [__] out of here
there's only like it you're like let me
just get this squeegee out
to clean you up and
it's a piece of ketchup on the corner
that's [__] ridiculous that's the
most insecure thing I've ever heard of
my God
that's insane is sex with hold on I
wanted to get back to the thing about
women care about load size I I mean a
small load is a bummer the size I've
never cared about that if you if you
don't come then I'm offended yeah really
but a big load you're like nice
yeah
yeah yeah
but that's yeah but that's honestly
that's so much more like what's been
going on though the days before than how
great the one session was you know what
I mean like you can you can you can like
knock my socks off but if I've come five
times already it's not gonna be sure
sure but it's the first time you're
[__] and load small
as a woman you're disappointed
I'm not disappointed I'm just offended
you're offended from a small load yeah
like I really don't I'm not like it's
more it's it's more it's more if it's a
big one you're like hell yeah but if
it's a small one you're like whatever
yeah
I know honestly he's really cute
I mean you can't control this [__] you
know what I mean
about to [__] blast through the
drywall and nothing there's nothing you
know
yeah that hurts me too it's like going
off the high dive and you just go
so many times you can bounce right dude
I've I've [__] up my own orgasm
knowing that I jerked off earlier in
that day and it's not going to be a big
load you are a [__] head case and I'm
like this is gonna be insane this is
gonna be so bummed when she says this
that is not and it's not representative
of how God
[Laughter]
[Applause]
dude a back pocket of metal geez
sometimes oh my God that was amazing
she's like oh my God that's my hair this
guy's a [__] Chief a sex with
conjoined twins a threesome
no
it's a trip to the psychiatrist dude
that's a nice hold on there there was a
there's only one [__] there was a live
uh there was a story we did at our live
show recently there was um two heads one
[__] the one girl had a boyfriend the
one girl was celibate so she just closed
her eyes while they knock around wait
because it's horrible Sensations
I think so
that's a good question I don't know how
like how they feel like it's not a good
question it's not worth it think about
us right now with one bird and you had a
girlfriend and you're like what do you
think about it I'm like I don't know
let's see what she does dude see what
she does to wear a hammer dude and then
she's just blowing no joke
we actually keep it we might actually
yeah let's give him some sloppy head I'm
like she ruled
she's not funny as [__] but she rules
it would be it would also bother me oh
[__] would you
rack porn you watch for the rest of your
life have a have music or be in a
foreign language foreign
I guess it depends to me though
sometimes you're watching some like
weird like Eastern European [__] and
they start talking and I feel like it's
like taken yeah you're talking about
your history
and you can shut the [__] up
you're not
you're not even cooler building like
what you're talking about though like
yeah some beautiful woman has like an
Italian accent fine when I when you're
watching some German [__] it's like
sounds a little like you know Arabic can
you watch a German girl fight for a life
that's a bit of a turn-off
in Russian turn the music on yeah
you [__] it to music
uh do I [__] him no no I mean I have I
will it's not I don't have like let me
go put my sex playlist on yeah if it's
like on and it happens that's a red flag
but I would say it's like one percent I
like to hear a lot of that yeah sounds
dude like the sounds of the game you
know the crack of the bat yeah
the crowd
I left a funeral home with tissue box
also I also I don't want the some guy
singing about hotter [__] that I'm doing
yeah man
a hundred percent you gotta read the
question
whoa do you think you could throw a
football farther than 1940s Heisman
winner
um
dude think about cuz you're going like
this this guy's crazy wait wait is this
like a trick question when do they
invent the forward pass 30s
it's not a trick question it's probably
like right around there that's why
that's why we did early yeah it's a
1940s Heisman Trophy winner you think
you throw a ball farther yeah they had
no dad that could throw football because
they didn't throw football their dads
were at War
but they also didn't throw footballs
everyone was learning
yeah I think you could
let's see would you rather wear high
heels or a belly shirt belly shirt what
high heels
you got a great I was gonna say you you
guys show the people no come on show the
people he's got a [__] up belly button
oh is that what it is I got a mid it's
been holding a throw up for [__] I
don't know that's fine to me it's a
little flat
you don't really have a belly it's not a
hole you have like a something right on
the middle it's a piece of gum
you know it's like that's an interesting
thing never seen a woman with an Audi
oh I have uh I've immediately left there
would you give up sex or be able to dunk
dude no
because being able to dunk a basketball
is one of the coolest [__] not if you
can't drop the net huh drop the net
being able to show up anywhere and like
throw down is a a objectively cool thing
wait hold on yeah
um I I know what you're saying homers
are like dunking over a guy any massive
talent and impetus is it's a nightmare
yeah yeah yeah the reason these guys all
right would you would you give up sex to
throw a hundred miles an hour no I would
never you could say anything save the
Holocaust [__] anything yeah save it
I mean keep it going
if you started you should get down to
like really because like when I give up
let's say if you could give up yeah now
we're talking like then you're like
would you give your eyesight to [__] the
ability
so yeah anything like let's say with a
100 mile an hour fast while you make it
professor especially you make millions
of dollars still no no you gotta have
sex what if I can't have sex forever
yeah can I throw 99 and still [__] no no
no
like I like the loophole yeah yeah yeah
you take a little bit off of it
okay yeah throw a breaking ball and bang
her yeah if you yeah
the other team's like you know O'Connor
was morning tonight so be ready for the
breaking ball we know he [__] earlier
so we know like the high heat is not
coming and there it is Jack another
slider it looks like Tommy's begging for
sex he's really been working on that
knuckleball
he's throwing under 50 every game who's
the worst group of fans easily easily
slip knot
yeah there's nothing worse they are I
mean they're the worst they're good
that's my answer forever and always yeah
it's pretty good
and the thing is you know what's kind of
great about it is they're just Fading
Into irrelevance You know like for so
long it was like I hate you because
you're winning and you're rubbing it in
my face and now it's just like every
year you're gonna lose we're gonna make
fun of you and we do this dance
overnight we're raised in greatness so
they have this like but that's the
position that attitude versus dude
that's ending see there's I know they're
so bad I don't even like talking about
it because they don't they're actually
good yeah almost like they feel Yankees
yes yeah I appreciate the the Yankee
fans who are here now are like I don't
remember the Glory Days so I'm like why
the [__] are you even acting like you
know tough [__] but they're starting to
stop they're like losers like the rest
of us yeah like I'm trying to go as
weird Sports scary part is that if they
come back I love that
yeah yeah they're going to come through
yeah yeah I'm a big fan of Juggalos dude
Tommy love you have you ever watch a
juggalo documentary
I've beaten off would you rather [__]
the hottest girl celebrity who has a
dick or Vin Diesel with a fuckman diesel
you're gonna [__] diesel okay no no
no no no no all right would you rather
[__] the hottest girl celebrity who has
a dick or vin so you're talking about
back [__] a hot chick with backflips
does she have a dick and a [__] or Vin
Diesel this is a hot it's a let me
rewrite it no yeah it's a hot girl she's
a dick she's not she doesn't have a
[__] would you [__] Vin Diesel with a
[__] or a hot girl with a penis yes a
hot girl with a penis a hundred percent
yeah I'd fold that like the wallet in
this last story see you later I don't
even look at it maybe I do plus it's
such a bizarre scenario you could be
like this is crazy but we have to do it
I mean theoretically you could do that
with Vin Diesel you can talk your way
through it you're just closing your eyes
and Vin Diesel and [__] a [__]
swollen testicle imagine like [__]
was just like
he's like an orange
would you rather [__] yourself every
time you come or get a boner every time
you talk to a dude
and like you can't even let's say no
like waistband let's say like this is
like your [__] people I'll tell them
as soon as I see him here's what's gonna
happen nice to meet you you're a great
guy don't be alone
it's gonna go awry
they're about to get real crazy yeah
we're gonna have a parade down here but
keep eyes locked here
what can you not [__] or something and
what's the well it's just that that was
something you're sitting at a [__]
business meeting you meet a guy for the
first time you're at a funeral you meet
a meet a teacher of your kid and your
dick gets hard that's the problem
okay
yeah you're just a [__] sexual like
deviant you're like known as the guy
with a boner everywhere you go yeah
I thought there was a yeah that's not
enough for you to just be like uh you
know do you get boners around dudes
oh yeah
yeah
that'd be another fun thing to just tell
someone about it just be like it was
either this is [__] myself
[Laughter]
I encountered the weirdest genius
quarter three numbers are down
you'd rather your girlfriend get a
notification every time you watch porn
with a description or a notification of
where you are at all times every time I
watch porn gotta with notification
yeah
um
I'll go porn yeah it's not even like if
you're I'm not even trying to find I'm
just saying like every time you want to
just like I'm getting a uh I'm gonna be
late like I'm stuck at work you're
actually getting a beer with your
buddies and she knows that because you
know you know you're also just how I
spend my day is so much more disgusting
than what I'm jerking off to
really what do you do where do you go to
the bed today
I see he's getting all my notifications
and she says Arab woman on one leg and
he's like Jesus Christ
three emails
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out